so then yeah i got on the plane and then
i almost felt too easy because i got
through checking and it was super easy
like was it easy for you as well yeah it
was very easy show them the paper they
were like yeah have have fun
yeah once once you get once you show the
paper which was the same for me like
going out the country once you show the
paper and everything's accepted then
it's like it's it's the most stressless
experience i've had in an airport
because it's [ __ ] empty because no
one's traveling so you're like no cue
for like security or anything you just
walk straight in
um and it's just it's just a breeze i've
never had like after everything got
accepted i've never had a
more pleasant experience in an airport
and i never i never thought you could
have a good experience in an airport
until until like until now
it was really chill i had a great time
at the airport it was i charge all my
devices i was like there was in my
terminal i think i counted there was
like 20 people in the whole waiting area
wow like the the whole thing yeah yeah
so you had like you know your whole
section to yourself it was really nice
pretty good yeah but then uh but then it
came to coming back into japan and we
always obviously talked about the
documents
that was just the start of the process
right because you get off the plane and
obviously you have to present the same
documents and everything like that
um and they put you they put you into
this like this queue of just checkpoints
and there's like eight checkpoints
that's before immigration
[ __ ] out so you do eight checkpoints
before you can even get to what is
normally the annoying part yeah yeah
yeah and i
you kind of like you you go in and you
give you they present you these
documents right and then they give you a
[ __ ] tag right that you have to put
over your hand
to identify you
that's exactly it so you're literally
like being cattle being herded through
how it's how they know you're going to
the quarantine hotel they put this
large
thing on your hands yeah like this
they literally they literally tag you
right i'm like
and i took it off for a second and
someone shouted at me because i wanted
to get my coat off and i took it off and
they were like like two men came over
like shouting and like panicking at me
and pointing at us put it back on and i
was like what the [ __ ] man like give me
a [ __ ] second
yeah so like you have to they give you
about like 17 million documents that
they will just like check a call like
across like this journey that you take
because and and the thing is like you
present this document they check it
great go to the next checkpoint they ask
for the same document
and they check it you go to the next
point now for some reason like this
these few documents that you you have
get checked
a total about like five times like by by
different checkpoints even though
nothing changed between you walking from
point a to point b right there's like
eight stops right so the first stop is
they
so this is also a thing right no one
told me this you have to keep your
boarding card
normally on airplanes i just like
[ __ ] the moment i'm on the plane i
just like put the boarding card in my
pocket scrambled up or something yeah
but that's really because you don't need
it anymore you're on the plane you do
you
the luggage the luggage tags what'd you
do with the luggage tags because that's
normally on your card oh no they
normally put that on your passport or
something oh really oh yeah but the
luggage tags i know i know my bag i've
never had to use it i i always hold onto
it until i'm out at the airport oh the
luggage tags i keep but normally the
boarding card i would like to scramble
in my pocket or something oh really
no one told me you needed it because you
never need it at an airport right i just
hold on to it just in case yeah just in
case you just throw it away i'm not like
on the plane [ __ ] tearing it up but
like yeah i don't think about it much
but yeah you needed it so when you get
off the plane they ask for like your
passport your boarding pass and the
documents now i printed off all the
documents that the japanese government
told me to have yep turns out that some
of them they just give you on the plane
anyway yep so i didn't need to print
them out so i did i didn't even end up
using my version i used the ones that
they printed out for me right uh because
it was like smaller and the one i
printed out was a4 and it was like a we
i yeah i didn't understand so so you
have these two documents one of them is
a declaration saying that you're a good
boy and you won't leave your house and
you won't break quarantine rules and if
you do they'll deport you okay um and if
you're a general not ominous at all yeah
and if you're a japanese national i
think they will do criminal charges or
something yeah i don't know how much
they're enforcing it um and another one
was uh you have to circle the countries
you came for you've been in the past 14
days yeah and then you sign your name
and stuff and then they always check
this and they put like they put a lot of
your information on the sheet i didn't
realize which sheet was going to be
important yeah so i didn't i didn't
either so yeah the first check is they
check those documents and the next one
is the wellness wellness check where
they take your temperature and then you
have to do a cover test immediately at
the airport okay so you use like a pcr
test not like uh antigen test as well so
the difference between a pcr test is you
have to like take your spit yeah whereas
with an antigen test i think you can
shove the thing in your nose
and it's like it's like an instant
almost an instant like response with the
energy test with the pcr it takes like
an hour you need a centrifuge
all i know is that they put it in the
centrifuge that's yeah yeah like that's
that's how
so you you get like asked oh you're
feeling okay uh you know they check your
temperature again i don't know what
happens if you have a high temperature i
assume they just like put you down like
they just like shoot you on the spot i
don't know like i don't
grab the pillow
i i imagine some like like
come out and just take you away like i i
don't know what happened
nobody so you get melted into the
because like it's chocolate [ __ ]
scary yeah you are literally treated
like cattle yeah yeah yeah like if you
anytime i asked anyone questions i got
like looked at like a [ __ ] weirdo why
is this cow talking yeah yeah yeah
so cause okay before we go on to uh i'll
explain more of the flow i don't know
okay i'll do it after so um you go to
the wellness check and then you need to
do a cover test immediately problem is
right i was really dehydrated and i need
to start spinning yeah yeah and i
couldn't spit anything i was just
spitting air like
and on the wall they had pictures of
plums and lemons to help you
to help you to help you get some saliva
and i'm like this is not helping
why did they not just give you a plum
no because you're not meant to like eat
or drink anything before you do it
because that will dilute like a result
um
yeah you do that you someone takes your
test you know they all look at you like
you're the devil
like but the thing is the thing is like
you're you're you're in a room right
where uh you're just full of a bunch of
people spitting yeah it's really [ __ ]
weird and they like spitting into this
container which is like which is pieces
of plums
yeah which is like which is like you
know you know really it's not really
like the nicest thing to watch people
spitting into this glass
this container right and sydney had like
sydney after being on his flight for
like 12 hours felt a bit queasy yeah you
know and i could just i could just hear
her in like the
container next to me because she was
feeling queasy before she had to do it
and her seeing people spitting around
she was just like
oh no
i felt so [ __ ] it smells so bad
because like
because yeah he does it does you do feel
a bit sick see that's just yeah a
stranger spit just be like just like
[ __ ] weird and uh that sounds so
post-apocalyptic yeah you do the
spitting thing you give it to someone uh
they check the documents that you have
the the right uh coveted barcode on your
thing and then you go to a place where
they make you give your email and then
they they send you an email and they
make sure you got it right and that's
okay that's fine and then they make you
install these apps i i pre-installed
them but then i had a problem this app
was so [ __ ] jank when i selected my
birth date as july it would randomly
just go back to june oh yeah yeah that's
something that happened today
yeah yeah yeah and i had to reinstall
the whole app and the internet was [ __ ]
and it wasn't installing for some reason
and they came over and they were like oh
here's a pocket wi-fi i'm like no i've
got 4g it's fine i don't know this app
is just dog [ __ ] i don't know what's
going on it like didn't install and that
it's this really [ __ ] weird thing
that's watching you fill out this this
app as well and i'm just like
sorry it's all right man you can you can
go and help someone else i'm all right i
can do this i can apparently the first
time but i can fill it out yeah and they
make you make sure that your google maps
thing is on and i was like yeah it's on
already it's always on there like can we
check and i'm like all right sure so i
showed them they're like okay good good
nice nice nice i'm like good yeah yeah
and then once i got that installed you
go to the waiting area to get your
covered test results
which takes a couple of hours right no
no no my mine took 30 minutes how long
did yours take um
waiting mine took about an hour okay
yeah mine's about 30 minutes but then i
and then you get get put into the bus
waiting area
and that was a long time i waited to be
shipped off to the butchers basically
basically and they've gotten it's weird
because they've got they've
laid you out like you're sitting on a
bus yeah do they do that for you as well
yeah they're in a corner and you're all
sitting like you are on a bus it's like
it's like a dress rehearsal it's like
you're on a bus you've literally like
what they do in school
that's exactly yeah where where like you
have like this teacher who leads you
onto the bus and you have to sit in like
the exact same way you sat down and i'm
just like what is this
yeah and and then you know once you've
got all that then okay so this whole
process this part took like three hours
yeah and then you can go through
immigration right which which takes a
while again yeah but luckily because
there's no uh no um people traveling
it's a little quicker yeah um but yeah
it does just take yeah so you're if you
if you fly back in japan at the moment
uh regardless of how quickly or how many
people are like flying in with you
you're gonna be in the airport for
around three to four hours i was there
for five before you get to immigration
um
before you can even get your bags
because i was i was there wondering am i
even gonna get gonna get my bags today
yeah like what's happening with that so
yeah so you're basically after your
12-hour journey which is what we had 12
13 hours on a plane you have to draw
another four hours in an airport being
herded
um through this through the system which
like it it kind of felt like this
dystopian society yeah
where you were just treated like cattle
like a piece of meat being hurted
through herded through uh you you you
know you were there to be processed
which is weird man because i don't know
what happens if you just don't follow
along
yeah it was just really weird and uh
very strange you are you are treated
almost like uh a disease rather than a
person yeah yeah um which you know i i
don't give a [ __ ] about it's whatever
but it's just weird um waiting for my
bags took so long because you have to
because obviously when you eat your bags
in the airport you can just go yeah
because we're all on the same bus i'm
all dirty travelers uh we have to all
wait till everybody's gone through and
everybody's got their bag and then you
can start going through the bag checking
yeah so you still you kind of once
you've got your bag you still gotta wait
and then i don't know if this happened
to you they bring out like search dogs
and stuff yeah and they checked
everything
oh and i was like oh my bro i'm i don't
think the dog can smell coved can it
like
what what is this i'm like this is a
joke and they like they were like i
didn't like interrogate you about what
you brought in no they were like asking
me like do you have any food and i was
like i mean i got like i got some snacks
and they're like what what's what is it
what is it with snacks and i'm like it's
like a nature bar and they're like does
it contain meat i'm like no it's a
[ __ ] nature bar i don't know like it
was just weird they were like grilling
me about like these cereal bars i had
and i was like it's a [ __ ] cereal bar
what do you mean look at it it sounds
like typical australian customs yeah
yeah i mean illustrate yeah it makes
sense right um and yeah we finally got
through it and i was talking to this old
japanese man because he'd lived in the
uk for like 20 years and he was like he
was just so funny he was just like i
miss pub already i like i miss my
friends i have good friends in pub and
i'm like yeah man i love the pub too
yeah and i was like why are you going to
he's like i'm going to um kyushu i'm
like going to accuse you what the [ __ ]
where because you can't how can you get
to kyushu yeah so he was quarantining in
tokyo two weeks and going to kyushu i
was like [ __ ] that jesus [ __ ] you know
yeah
this poor guy was like 70 and
because this guy was a seven year old
japanese man they didn't even try and
make him wear a mask like he just took
it off and no one told him to put it on
anyone else who even took it off they
stopped and they were like put your mess
back on what are you [ __ ] playing
squid game all of a sudden like this
literally like he's like
old guy i immediately
yeah we were just chatting the whole
time but i i was like bro i think you
should put your i told him i felt like i
think you should put your mascot he's
like they won't make me put it on
he's like i'm too old they won't make me
do it and to be fair
i was really impressed he was he was
that kind of amazing old man that just
did not give a [ __ ] anymore yeah yeah
he's like i'm far too old to give [ __ ]
about your rules yeah which i respect
also i was like bro they've got guns man
put the mask on it's literally squid
game they have guns bro put them
i'm trying to help him out here
my god and we are we got through of
course this old man they didn't make him
[ __ ] open his bag or do anything yeah
and i'm next up they make me [ __ ]
open my bag and i've got like three bags
and i'm like ah for [ __ ] sake he's
like do you smoke cigarettes and i'm
like no and he's like what about tobacco
and i'm like no
and then he's like do you have any i'm
like no i just said no what can i have a
song
i just want to hit man
after that after you finally get through
all that i'm assuming this is the same
for you yeah you get on the bus we had
to wait 30 minutes for it to [ __ ] go
yeah then because it was peak traffic
hours at this point it took an hour and
a half to get to the [ __ ] hotel
so not fun